I was ranked four times in the world
most famous competition as a top
sculper. My return was more than 500%
over 12 months. And this is the official
track record. And I did this because
unlike most retail traders, I use a
special chart. These are called deep
charts, orderflow charts. They don't
simply show you price candlesticks. They
actually shows you the interaction
between buyers and sellers. And you can
filter the small traders that doesn't
mean much with the big traders, the
smart and informed money and see what
they are actually doing. In this video,
I will show you how as a beginner you
can start using orderflow, how these
charts exactly works so you can take
more informed decisions and boost your
edge and your trading performance. We
are in the candlestick chart of 19 of
September 2025
and we are watching the interaction
between buyers and sellers. You can see
the buyers protecting this horizontal
area of 24,800
and the sellers protecting the area of
24,825
to 26. This interaction is what we can
actually see from price action. So in
this case what a price action trader
will do is will typically wait for the
breakout of this level to understand a
continuation in structure because
usually it's used you you can call
change of market structure you can call
chalk you can call breakout there are a
lot of uh way to call it but anyway what
you don't have is the actual interaction
of orders to see this and to get an
advantage over the other traders. You
can activate the order flow values that
is giving you a breakdown of the delta
and the total volume and giving you a
color coding to show how much the
sellers or buyers are aggressive with an
actual number. In this case, you can see
that buyers got really aggressive on the
top, but they didn't manage to break
through. So you can see that here they
are being absorbed really heavy by the
sellers. But in this case you can see
that 599 of delta in a total volume of
2,800 and 332
try to do the same from the low part and
got absorbed. So when you have this case
uh punched to the wall by the sellers
with absorption and a huge aggression of
the buyers because you can see a
all-time high on volume 4,600 with 812
of delta. What you can expect is that
the next move will give you a breakout
and this is a way to get anformational
advantage over the price action traders.
What the market does is that it don't
come to visit again this area that got
already protected. But you see sellers
try to protect the level but then the
price skyrocket. And this is the actual
price action that we have at the moment.
By the way, we are going to launch our
platform deep charts really soon. So
click the link in the description if you
want to save your spot. Now let's deep
dive in the concept of fair value gap.
What is a fair value gap?
When when there is an imbalance in price
action, this is typically wrong because
to identify a real fair value gap, you
need to get inside the candle and you
need to see how the volume transacted.
This is what it's actually fair value
gap or void. What we use in this case to
get more precise is the fixed profile.
Now I will give you some example. Price
action traders will wait for the market
to reclaim this level because from their
perspective this one it's a fair value
gap. Okay. But in this case you can go
deep dive and don't miss on this
movement by getting the fixed profile I
will show you on this wing
from the point A to point B and removing
the price action. Okay. When you remove
the price action and deep dive,
you can see that the lowest volume of
interaction in all the area of value
area. So where 70% of the volume got
transacted is exactly this one
is the level that goes from 24,318
to 24,317.
Is it's a small level. It's not even an
area. Okay. This is what actually in all
this range and in this value area it's
the fair value gap. It's where the
volume didn't transacted in a balanced
way. And what you will see thousand of
times is that this is exactly where the
price will reject. So I strongly advise
you to implement this concept even if
you are a price action trader because
you can get more precise, more sharp and
save a lot of headache trying to find
the correct area. Now we will go through
an example of pressure. So how can we
create a proxy of pressure for market
participants? In this case, we are in uh
the chart of NASDAQ and we are in a
compressed area where buyers are pushing
really hard to break the level and the
market is compressing. But the first
question that a trader can ask is we
will be in accumulation or we will be in
distribution. We will go up or down
because it's not clear. Okay. In this
case, you can use volume to help you and
understand the pressure of the
cumulative volume delta compared to
price. That's the secret. This is called
volume spread analysis. So understanding
the result on the price for the proxy of
the volume. And I will show you an
example because here it can seem like
the price wants to create a breakout.
Okay? Wants to go down. Then it tends to
be a failed auction. But a lot of
traders maybe can see open candle and
try the breakout and test. Why going
long in this case? I will explain to you
using the cumulative volume delta that
it's an amazing indicator that gives you
a sense of the pressure of the market.
And in this case you can see that we
have a lower low on the cumulative
volume delta here while the market is
still on the same level as before. This
is what it's called it's called
absorption. Okay. So there are passive
buyers here that are absorbing all the
aggressive sellers and the market is not
willing to go down. All this candle got
completely absorbed. Okay. In this case
you can confirm objectively with the
absorption pattern the failuction. You
can get a clear direction for the day.
And you can also get a trend following
trades when the delta don'ts match with
the price. Because when you are in a
momentum phase like this one and you can
see a huge amount of aggression
following an absorption, you can
understand that the buyers are in
control. Okay. But how can you jump on
the trend in this case? You can jump on
the trend in this case using exactly the
relationship between cumulative volume
delta and price. I will give you an
example. In this case, we have a sell
candle that tried to create a lower low,
but on the correspondent part, we have a
huge absorption. All this pressure got
zero results, but you continue to see
sellers trying to go down here. This is
again an absorption of sellers. So, it's
a mismatch in price and volume. And this
is a nice way uh to use the cumulative
volume delta to create a proxy and to
confirm your trade with a high
probability of being right. So, I hope
you enjoy this video. This is uh a way
to get deeper inside the candle and get
a deep understanding of the market
mechanics. And I hope I will see you in
the next video on this channel. So
subscribe.